hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter 6 of his book language truth
and logic a jair is going to set out
what has come to be called an emotivist
theory of ethics and the version of it
that a Jair has he's treating it as a
sort of meta ethic that is a higher
level discourse that allows us to
account for what's going on and what
people think is going on in ethics and
why it's not actually what it is that
they think is going on in a way you
could say the air is trying to provide
us with an analysis from a higher level
that shows us why all of the people
putting forth ethical theories and
disagreeing with each other are not just
in in some respect wrong but off base
that they're they're talking past each
other and they're misunderstanding their
subjects so emotivism claims to provide
a view on ethical statements theories
expressions whatever it is that you want
to say anything that has to do with
value in a moral sense applying to our
actions or words it claims to provide
some sort of analysis of this that will
show what's really going on
and for air and for other emotivist this
has to do with our emotions or desires
preferences he also uses the term Moral
Sentiments at one point so the things
that we feel about about ethics or about
right and wrong good and bad all of
those sorts of feelings that we have
that that have come to us primarily
through our upbringing and background
and perhaps through some education as
well
now emotivism is not just a meta ethic
sort of above the fray of ethics it also
does represent a more substantive view
on ethics and a sort of bottom level
giving us some ideas about how we ought
to approach things so it's not totally
mad ethical but but eras version of it
remains primarily there and we should
begin by looking at this framework that
he's setting out and there's this
wonderful sentence before that we should
remind ourselves of what he's been doing
in the rest of the chapter so he's been
examining other major theories of ethics
and saying why it is that they don't do
what they're supposed to be doing
looking at the distinction between fact
and value and examining how it is that
we use language in ethical judgments
statements propositions so this ear will
go on and say that in every case so this
is unequivocally this is categorically
in every case in which one would
commonly be said to be making an ethical
judgment of any sort right the function
of the relevant ethical word is purely
emotive notice he's not saying that the
entire statement itself has a function
that's purely emotive there could be a
lot of factual information which might
be verifiable or might not that that
could certainly be
propositional in the other sense you
know able to be true or false but the
ethical component of it the ethical word
or words its function he's saying is
purely emotive now what does it mean to
have an emotive function there's a
number of different sub functions
entailed within what he's calling the
emotive function so going back to his
own words he says it's used to express
feeling about certain objects but not to
make any assertion of them so what are
we talking about a little bit earlier he
says in saying that a certain type of
action is right or wrong I'm not making
any factual statement not even a
statement about my own state of mind I'm
merely expressing Moral Sentiments
and the man who's ostensibly
contradicting me is merely expressing
his Moral Sentiments neither of us is
asserting a genuine proposition so what
are Moral Sentiments
well approval and disapproval are the
ones that he I think takes to be most
basic but we could also talk about
things like resentment or anger you know
a sense that something has been violated
and somebody ought to be punished or
payback for it we might think about
other moral sentiments like joy or
sadness when I approve of something
perhaps the approval that I am giving is
because whatever I'm seeing or whatever
is happening makes me feel happy to look
at you know I see the proverbial Boy
Scout helping the old lady cross the
street and I say hmm that's good I
really like that that makes me feel as
my old philosophy instructor used to say
that gives me warm and fuzzy inside
right as opposed to mmm that's bad cold
and prickly I see the boy scout luring
the old lady across the street and
dropping her down an open manhole oh
that's not good at all right what's
going on there is an expression of my
feeling
Ayer says that one of the the sort of
sub functions of this emotive function
of the the terminology that we're using
there is to express our feelings or
Moral Sentiments and he says that this
did not make an assertion so this is
this is worth dwelling on a little bit
because he also tells us that there is a
tendency to to view this language as if
it is expressing our sentiments in such
a way as to make an assertion I am
feeling this this is what I feel towards
that so a little bit later he says here
we go I'm not really making any
statement about my own feelings or about
anything else
I'm only evincing my feelings which is
not the same as saying that I have them
the distinction between the expression
of feeling and the assertion of feeling
is complicated by the fact that the
assertion that one has a certain feeling
often accompanies the expression of that
feeling and is then a factor in the
expression of that feeling so he uses
the example of boredom to get this
across I may feel bored right and I can
express that in a number of ways
many of them are nonverbal the silent
language to use the title of a book like
you know I look around and roll my eyes
big-sized slouched a bit you know maybe
somebody's talking and I'm doodling away
and I'm like looking somewhere else
all of these are expressions of boredom
right but I could also just say oh I'm
so bored all right and in that case he
says I can simultaneously express
boredom and say that I'm bored and in
that case my utterance of the words I am
bored is one of the circumstances which
make it true to say that I am expressing
or evincing boredom but I can't express
boredom without actually saying that I'm
bored I can express about my tone and
gestures while making a statement about
something wholly unconnected with it or
by an ejaculation that is a
sort of Phatak expression or without
uttering any words at all so air is less
interested in assertion and why because
an assertion would actually be something
factual if I say I am feeling the
feeling of boredom right now or when I
see the Boy Scout stealing the Girl
Scouts cookies
from the table where they're selling
them ooh that makes me mad or I need to
ploor that or you know anything along
those lines that that's more assertion
right I'm telling somebody how I feel
instead I can just express how I feel
like I said Boy Scouts bad right
and in that case I'm basically going boo
I don't like that I'm expressing my my
feeling so that is what emotivist take
much of our moral language our moral
judgments the things that we share in
this common space either by writing or
by speaking or in other ways they take
that to be at the essence of what we're
doing simply expressing emotion simply
expressing how it is that we feel inside
of ourselves showing other people in
some way what it is that that we in fact
you know approve of disapprove of other
feelings that that we have there's one
other major function to emotivist
language though and a motive Asteria
vesical language and that is that
ethical terms as he says also function
to do two other things they function to
arouse feeling and they function to
stimulate action now we might think of
this primarily applying to other people
right
I see the Boy Scout go it you know
sliding over to the Girl Scout table and
I can tell he's thinking about stealing
the Girl Scout cookies and I say to
somebody else over there stop him
right that's a direct command but I
could also
say things let's say there's a long term
problem of Boy Scouts you know taking
Girl Scouts cookies I can write an op-ed
piece and say it is deplorable that Boy
Scouts are stealing Girl Scouts cookies
what I'm saying there is you should stop
them or I'm not just saying I don't like
that I'm also saying you shouldn't like
that either right and you know you could
think about the ways in which we
emphasize this and all the ways in which
moral indoctrination really does work
you know when we're bringing up children
or trying to reformulate people's you
might call it emotional moral manifold
through training
we often say this is good this is bad
right and even if we say it in a neutral
tone of voice what are we actually
signalling to them they should also view
this as good meaning they should have a
positive emotional orientation towards
it and they should not do that sort of
action why because that will be
disapproved of and perhaps if they come
to internalize our own values they come
to feel and think of it in the same way
likewise when we say this is bad and you
you should not do it so what's really
going on linguistically then is that
ethical language the components of
propositions that have ethical terms are
really just either expressions of our
feeling which may be accompanied by some
sort of assertion but need not be or
they are disguised commands they're not
really propositions they are imperative
they're saying feel this do this don't
feel this don't do this they're none of
these are propositions which means that
none of them can actually be true or
false now it you can go to a meta level
and say it is true that dr. Sadler in
expressing you know this particular
thing was also giving me a command but
that's not saying that the CIM
and itself is true or false you're now
making a metalinguistic statement about
a command that that I gave to you if I
tell you good students hand their papers
in on time right what I'm doing is I'm
expressing my own warm fuzzy towards
certain kinds of students in certain
kinds of behavior and perhaps also by
implication expressing cold pricklies my
disapproval of students who don't hand
their things on in on time but I'm also
saying listen buddy hand your stuff in
on time all right I'm trying to give you
some sort of proverbial kick in the
pants to get you to do something and to
feel something you should feel guilty
for not getting your stuff in on time
guilt is a immoral emotion right so all
of this hopefully illustrates what's
going on none of it is actually true or
false now whether you have an emotion or
not that is true or false but that's an
assertion that's not an expression and
so you know we can step back and make
all sorts of assertions but that's not
the Emotiv function of language now what
is the implication of this for ethics
part of the implication would be that
all of these people who think that
ethics is really about moral facts or
about describing the way things are in
the world and not about values that we
hold rather irrationally we don't have
good reasons to hold the values that we
do there is no possibility of rationally
reconstructing what the best account
would be or anything like that we simply
have them that's it that's all ethics
can do ethics error will go on to say at
another point is largely a matter of
psychology or sociology the parts of it
that actually do have to do with with
directly ethical terms this is what's
going on it's only an expression of
emotion an attempt to induce emotion and
others or to produce some sort of action
on their part some conformity to what it
is that that we want moral disagreements
also become rather and
a cable because we're not debating about
something that another person could say
is true or is false so that becomes a
significant problem as well so if that's
really the case an affair is right about
this there's a good portion of what
we've traditionally looked at as ethics
that becomes largely untenable but it's
replaced with this emotivist theory
you